I'd like to start off by presenting just
pictures of
the precipitation distribution looks
like on earth during the northern
hemisphere in southern hemisphere summer
seasons I've drawn red boxes around what
many people think of as the monsoon
regions of the planet and the point of
this plot is really to show you that you
have this migration of the rainy zones
from one side of the equator to the
other side of the Equator as you go from
one solstice season to the other
solstice season and note that the
precipitation is is highly concentrated
zonely in longitude in these in these
monsoon regions and some of them are
stronger than others especially the
south asian monsoon here it is we have
it is is stronger and located further
poleward than any of the other monsoon
regions now those are that precipitation
distribution that you saw is a result of
highly three-dimensional circulations
but it's common practice and and it
works decently well to to have a
conceptual model to think of the
circulation that produces that rainfall
distribution in in two dimensions as a
function of latitude and height and the
idea is that you have this continent
here located in the summer hemisphere
and you have a thermally direct
circulation with warm air rising in the
summer hemisphere cold air sinking in
the winter hemisphere and because we're
on a rotating planet the winner
hemisphere has trade winds winds blowing
from the east to the west those trade
winds are reversed to become the
low-level monsoon westerlies in the
summer hemisphere and in the upper
troposphere we have we have easterly
wind now as this warm air is rising it's
cooling adiabatically as as the pressure
drops and precipitation forms and falls
out and it's really a sort of old view a
traditional view that this circulation
this whole circulation sort of forced by
contrast in temperature between the land
surface and the ocean I you can somehow
you can go a little bit beyond that and
say well
is this a precipitation that forms when
the water vapor condenses you have you
have heat that's released and it's
actually also somewhat common even even
in the modern day monsoon literature to
see statements to the effect of that
this latent heating associated
precipitation is driving this enter
hemispheric circulation we've come be on
that a little bit and and we know now
that precipitation we can't really think
of it as a forcing for the large scale
flow it's really part of the solution if
you will and so what I'm going to do in
the rest of this talk is really present
a thorough Amick framework that allows
us to think of these large-scale
tropical overturning circulation in
which precipitation falls out in the
ascending branch of the circulation and
I'm going to start off by really telling
you about that framework and how we
think and using it to think about
precipitation in the large-scale flow
and then go on and look at several
applications so the the gist of it is is
that when we when we think of something
like the boundary layer of Earth's
atmosphere over a desert we we have this
dry convection we've this these
turbulent motions in the boundary layer
say that we're over the Sahara Desert
and the temperature profile and the
vertical follows a dry adiabatic falls
off at a rate of about 10 Kelvin per
kilometer as you go up we we don't think
of this dry convection as sort of a heat
source we think of it as simply
maintaining this this vertical profile
of temperature in response to some heat
flux from the surface into the
atmosphere and some radiative cooling of
the the column the atmospheric column
and so the argument is that you can do
the same thing with moist convection
that moist convection looks very
different from dry convection the upward
motions tend to be more concentrated in
space the downward and stronger and the
downward motions are weaker but they are
nevertheless these these turbulent
motions
occur in and around clouds that
constrain the temperature structure the
free troposphere to be near that of a
moist adia bat which falls off at a
weaker rate than 10 Kelvin per kilometer
somewhere closer to six Kelvin per
kilometer buttocks variable both in
height as well as it varies with what
temperature you're at and the relevant
condition instead of starting off at the
surface temperature and falling at 10
Kelvin per kilometer with height the
relevant variable to consider at the
bottom of a moist adiabatic the
equivalent potential temperature which
is a function of both the humidity and
the temperature so it's roughly a
measure of the energy content and that
that leads me to my next slide where I'm
going to introduce this Bay de variable
the equivalent potential temperature
it's it's increases linearly with with a
temperature but it also scales
exponentially with the with the water
vapor content it's it behaves similarly
to the moist static energy which is the
energy that you would get if you added
the energy that's in sort of the
specific heat of the air x the
temperature so the energy and the the
internal energy team the dry component
of the air and then you add in the
energy that you would get if you
condensed all the vapor the water vapor
to liquid and then you add a
geopotential term now this this
convective cause equilibrium idea is
basically that variations in this low
level theta e this equivalent potential
temperature at the bottom of a moist
idea bat look like variations in
temperature through the depth of the
convecting layer and I've drawn a
schematic here for how that that works
that if you if you warm or moisten the
boundary layer by increment and thus
increase the equivalent potential
temperature that they de of boundary
layer air you make the troposphere more
convectively unstable you get a break
out of deep connect
which heats the free troposphere and you
get cold and dry air descending from
those convective regions into the
boundary layer just like you do before a
thunderstorm you feel this you know this
cool air coming down from the free
troposphere these these gusts and that
reduces the boundary layer theta E and
you end up with the final state that's
that has a higher theta e in a higher
temperature than it did originally but
the variation the change in the
temperature of the troposphere and in
that of the better there are roughly the
same in other words on the previous
slide you just slide from this Moines
India back to a warmer more CD of that
word baby and sort of fun vertically
average temperature both move together
now this has a particular flavor in
monsoon regions because this this idea
of convective quasi equilibrium that
this that variations in the boundary
layer beta e or energy content sort of
track together with variations in
tropospheric temperature that only works
in regions where your convecting through
the depth of the troposphere when you
have these strong overturning
circulation in Earth's atmosphere in the
subsiding branch of the circulation
which occupies most of the domain
actually you suppress deep convection
and you warm the free troposphere
adiabatically just like you cool it
adiabatic Lee in the ascending regions
so the area where the theta e of the the
boundary layer is coupled to the free
tropospheric temperatures is limited to
these convecting regions that are near
the ascending branch of the circulation
in the rest of the domain your free
choice furyk temperature is is warmer
than the boundary layer theta E and what
that means is that in these when you
have a strong thermal a direct
overturning circulation in the tropics
you expect to see the theta e of the
boundary layer air to have a maximum in
the same position as the maximum of free
tropospheric temperature and then the
rest of the domain the two are decoupled
but they'll sort
treacherous current temperature has a
sort of gradual slope boundary layer can
have more very more spatial variability
and theta II just cuz humidity can vary
quite easily in the boundary layer and
so this is sort of this simple
conceptual model for for a monsoon
circulation this cross circuit Oriole
circulation where what convection does
is it doesn't drive the flow it simply
maintains the the tropospheric
temperature neuro moist adiabatic tied
to the theta II of the boundary layer
and so energy sources of things that
altered boundary layer theta II become
of central importance I'm going to get
to some observations some actual
observations of the real world in a
little bit but first I want to show your
results from a simple model to show you
how this works when we when we enforce
this idea of convective quasi
equilibrium and this is sort of results
from what you can think of as a two
layer model we have sort of the
troposphere divided into two layers air
can converge in the bottom layer and
diverge in the top layer and then you
have a mass flux between the two layers
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to sort of simulate a monsoon
circulation without a continent by
starting off by putting in a off
equatorial sea surface temperature
anomaly as sort of a proxy for the land
surface thermal forcing that you would
get in a monsoon climate and so this is
a this is our our thermal forcing if you
will for the circulation it's an SST
maximum centered at about 25 degrees
that SST imprints itself essentially on
the boundary layer theta E which is a
solid line right here you have a
northward wind that increases as you go
from the cold winter hemisphere and
toward this SST maximum and then and
then the northward wind abruptly
decreases in this very narrow
convergence zone where you have a large
vertical ascent and precipitation upward
convective mass flux the that convection
that deep
affection couples the boundary layer
energy content the theta e to the free
tropospheric temperature which is shown
in this dashed line and you can see here
that the two of these these Maxima that
are located in the same exact position
and in out away from that maximum where
you have substance the free tropospheric
temperature is higher than this boundary
layer theta e now this is an idea that
has sort of this is an idea from from a
model a simple model that I've
constructed but but this idea of
convective quasi equilibrium of of
large-scale tropical circulations has
been used for for a couple decades now
in a number of different contexts but
but really the consistency with
observations hasn't really been that
well examined so that's what I'm going
to do is show you a couple slides to
answer the question our observations
consistent with this conceptual
framework that we've constructed for
monsoon circulations and what you can
see here are the upper tropospheric
temperature in black lines the boundary
layer theta ian colors and it's probably
hard to scissor when we can turn off
these um lights that are shining
directly on the screen here probably not
alright so you can see this a black lot
this this is the thin black lines or
coastlines so this is a India right here
the Horn of Africa the maritime
continent is in this region and you can
see sort of Japan toward their the point
of this plot is really that the boundary
layer theta II has a maximum that's
located almost directly under the free
tropospheric temperature maximum and we
can go to other regions I'm only going
to show you two for purposes of time
this is Africa right here you can see a
West Africa the Sahara Desert will be up
here this is Southern Africa and
boundary layer theta is the colors has a
maximum directly under the free
troposphere temperature maximum which is
outlined in black and just like the
simple schematic that I showed you
earlier the precipitating region which
is outlined here in white is sort of
located just a little bit equatorward of
these thermal maximum which which we
expect from simple theory we we expect
the circulation to be sort of driven by
these tropospheric temperature gradients
until you get the maximum ascent where
you have a gradient of temperature in
the troposphere so this raises a
question of well okay this this I've
shown you what is essentially sort of a
diagnostic framework it we we know that
the free tropospheric temperature and
the boundary layer of theta II the
boundary layer energy content have to
hang together in this way but neither of
them are really we can't think of the
boundary layer theta II as being being
set externally and so the question is
well what is the ultimate forcing for
the flow so theta is really part of the
solution it interacts with the flow it
can even be affected by the flow 11
approach recently is that's become
popular is to think of tropical
circulations being driven by the source
of energy into the atmospheric column so
where you're heating the atmospheric
column that's where you tend to have a
scent where you cool it you have
subsidence and this is an equation for
the vertically integrated these brackets
represent a verdict
integral moist static energy so the
total energy content when you add in the
energy that's stored in water vapor and
if we're thinking about the steady-state
sort of a seasonal average we can set
this time derivative 20 and then we just
have a divergence of an energy flux has
to be equal to whatever the column
energy sources sort of the surface
evaporation the surface sensible heat
flux minus whatever you energy you
extract from the column by radiative
cooling now an interesting thing is that
this also interacts with the flow is
shown by this plot here from that which
is a plot from that simple model that I
just showed you of the surface heat flux
which is shown in the dashed line and
the near surface stay to e which is the
green line and the interesting thing is
that the the theta E has a peak that's
actually located poleward of the peak
column energy source the peak surface
heat flux is which is column energy
source is dominated by the surface heat
flux and that's because this surface
heat flux is actually interacts with the
circulation also it's elevated by high
surface wind speeds and convective
downdrafts which cool the air and allow
more more evaporation to be put to occur
in this region so we can see that we
have this it's consistent we have this
thermally direct circulation with
ascending air the diverges energy out of
this region diverges the energy that's
put into that column by the surface heat
fluxes in the radiative field now
observations are really consistent with
that sort of picture these are this is a
climatologist data from ecmwf three
analyses for july for the south asian
region and using the same colored
schematics the same color scheme the
green line shows the near-surface theta
e that peaks at about 25 degrees or so
and the dashed blue line that is
sorry it says surface heat flux here but
it's actually the vertically integrated
source of energy into the atmospheric
column and you can feed that it Peaks
actually well equatorward of the peak
boundary layer energy content and that's
the cause over the ocean we actually
have sort of a relaxation boundary
condition for those of you who are maybe
a little more mathematically oriented
where over land we have a flux boundary
condition so the ocean is being sort of
air over the ocean is sort of pegged to
it's it's constrained to be have a
temperature and humidity that are
determined by the SST whereas over land
we're sort of putting a certain amount
of energy into the column by surface
heat fluxes and so things like surface
land surface albedo and the total amount
of greenhouse gases in the column become
what determines the total amount of
energy flux over land but combined those
can give us these sorts of distributions
and this is consistent with that simple
model that I showed you earlier where we
have a where we have a ascending region
that's under this an ascending region
that lies directly over this peak source
of energy into the column and a little
bit equator we have a peak boundary
layer de tui or energy content now
that's a simple model that I'm going to
use to look at in a couple different
applications and show you that well this
is maybe you know as somewhat esoteric
in some ways view of tropical
circulations but we can use it for some
very concrete purposes this is a global
view I was sort of focusing in on this
South Asian region here on previous
slide but now you can see the Americas
in Africa where I've plotted again the
upper tropospheric temperature and the
boundary layer theta e are actually here
it's a moist static energy in a global
view again a climatologist summer and
you can see that what stands out is
really this South Asian monsoon region
here it has a temperature maximum
that is is global in nature the stretch
is about halfway around the globe and is
stronger than any of the other monsoon
regions and the low-level theta II over
South Asia is elevated as a maximum that
stretches well inland when we zoom in on
that region we see that this is a again
the Indian subcontinent right here this
is the Tibetan Plateau outlined in blue
and you can see that this boundary layer
theta e the maximum lies over this river
basin here of the Indus and Ganges
rivers and it sort of runs has a maximum
that runs right up against the
topography you can actually see sharp
gradient sin theta e that are coincident
with the topography and that really
suggests a hypothesis for the role play
played by topography in the South Asian
monsoon that you have these dry desert
regions and and although the air is hot
over these these desert regions of
Western Asia its humidity is so low that
that makes the total energy content of
that desert air quite low in comparison
to this warm but very moist air over
over India and so that this suggests
that the topography is maintaining these
sharp gradients in theta ii by
preventing mixing of the low-energy air
over the desert with a high energy or in
this moist monsoon region and that
that's what's making this South Asian
monsoon so strong and located so far
poleward now that is a very different
view of of what drives the monsoon
circulation the South Asian monsoon
circulation from from what has been
traditionally thought this is a
schematic from a paper by Prell at all
in 1992 but it really I used it just
because it encapsulate sin a brief form
a theory that goes back to some papers
in the 70s and even earlier I think
in the 50s which posit that the Tibetan
Plateau actually is a dominant forcing
for the South Asian monsoon that it's
just this elevated land surface is
really broad horizontally broad elevated
land surface absorbs solar energy and
because of its elevation and broadness
heats the troposphere at mid levels and
creates via a positive feedback with
moist convection this giant
interhemispheric South Asian monsoon
circulation I'm going to show you some
model results that that are that support
the idea that I put forth previously two
slides ago which are inconsistent with
the idea that the Tibetan Plateau is
sort of a dominant heat source for the
South Asian monsoon i'm showing you four
plots here one in which whether the top
left is is a climatologist it's like
what i showed you before here you can
see the Tibetan Plateau this is a
topography agen coastlines outlined here
here's eastern africa and note that you
have a high precip in this south asian
region it's it's very a spaceship very
it's highly variable in space and this
is a model simulation from a high
resolution climate model where what you
can see is that we're doing a very good
job with this model of reproducing this
observed precipitation field this is
actually a remarkably good simulation of
south-asian precipitation there's some
deviations here sort of when you get
into the western Pacific but we're we're
mainly concerned with this region in
here and overall for a climate model
which tend to switch tend to sort of
smear out precip in these regions quite
a bit this is remarkable remarkably good
I now I'm showing you here on on the
right changes in precipitation for two
configurations of that climate model
one is a model where I've just removed
all the topography so the surface is
basically just been made flat and you
can see that the blue regions signify a
decrease in precip relative to this
control case and the red region signify
an increase in precip and you get a very
large horizontally extensive reduction
in precipitation when you remove all the
topography this is a response that
people have seen in a lot of climate
models previously and people have taken
this as evidence for the fact that the
Tibetan Plateau is this is a sort of
needed to maintain a strong South Asian
monsoon now when you but I've done
something a little bit different here is
we've we've flattened the plateau itself
but we've maintained the or Agra fee
this is sort of narrow band of mountains
Himalayas Hindu Kush mountains that
stretch along that that sort of bound
that region of high boundary layer theta
E and what you see is you see that the
precip change is much weaker it's sort
of you have you know some signal but
it's fairly noisy and you have roughly
equal increase in decrease a fairly weak
magnitude in this region and if you look
at the winds this is a change in the low
level wind you see a substantial
decrease in the intensity of your
monsoon westerlies your Somali jet here
you have very little change in the wind
in these black vectors and to return to
that thermodynamic view that I used
previously when we look at the theta II
of the boundary layer this is what the
control model looked like you can see
this high beta eer stretching over
northern India when we eliminate all the
topography you get a great decrease in
this thermal maximum when you eliminate
all the topography but when you
eliminate just the Tibetan Plateau but
maintain the Himalayas you locally
reduce boundary layer theta you over the
plateau itself but you perturb the
thermal maximum south of the plateau
by almost nothing and when we look at
the correlation of boundary layer theta
e with the strength of the South Asian
monsoon in that model integration that I
just showed you as well as nine
different experiments where we perturb
the topography and perturb the surface
heat fluxes just by shutting off surface
sensible and latent heat fluxes in
different parts of the domain to get a
sense of what what what is the region
that's contributing most to South Asian
monsoon strength this is a map of the
correlation coefficients over all those
nine experiments between boundary layer
theta II and South Asian monsoon
strength than you see that the region's
worth beta e is strongly correlated with
the strength of the monsoon is in mostly
in this region over northern India here
where the thermal maximum life it's no
surprise if by this sort of
thermodynamic framework that I presented
previously over the plateau itself
there's relatively weak correlations now
this is not to say that the Tibetan
Plateau couldn't be important I it would
be a strong heat source I simply by
virtue of its elevation it's actually
known that if you take a service and you
increase its height you increase the
temperature that the troposphere
equilibrates at over that elevated
surface but the Tibetan Plateau also has
high albedo and this is a series of
curves from a mop series of model
integrations that were done by a peter
mullan r & Carey manual in the late
1990s where they calculated the
temperatures over a surface as you raise
to that surface and if you changed the
albedo so that's what these these sort
of kwasi vertical lines represent
surface temperature at
heights and then if you move to
different lines to the left you're
increasing the albedo and these curved
lines are just moist 80 of bats where
you move up from the the surface up
along a moist ad back through the
troposphere and the point here is that
if you take the the albedo of the Indian
Ocean if you move up in in height yes
you would you would be much warmer than
a moist adiabatic from the surface but
if you reduce the surface albedo to by
roughly the same difference between the
ocean and the Tibetan Plateau you more
than compensate for the effects of
elevation now this is this is a very
crude model that was done in the late
90s and we're actually a shinning who
was in the audience is that working to
reproduce this in a more modern cloud
resulting model but an aside that I'd
like to note is that climate models
actually poorly simulate the albedo of
the Tibetan Plateau maybe not all of
them but uh but this is a plot of the
standard deviation of surface albedo
during July and then during January
across the ensemble of seemeth three
models and we could update this a seam
of five I don't necessarily expect it to
look too different and an interesting
thing is that we have a standard
deviation across this ensemble of
climate models of point2 that means that
you know the standard deviation is about
twenty percent of the incoming radiation
is being reflected you know different
differences on that order between these
models which is huge you know if you
think about that worrying about
radiative forcings of 4 watts per meter
squared for global change you know that
these are ready to forcings of tens of
watts per meter squared so I'd like to
move on to another application which is
a interannual variability of climate I
really asking the question can this sort
of simple thermodynamic framework for
monsoon circulations help us understand
and interannual variability of tropical
precipitation and this is a plot from a
previous paper by hurling at all 2006
where they've done savvy common exercise
which is to create some precipitation
index here they made of precipitation
index for the Sahel region of Africa by
drawing a box around the Sahel averaging
precipitation within that region then
correlating that index with sea surface
temperatures and you get this signal you
find that there's a red here as negative
so they find that there's a sort of a
negative correlation between Sahel
precipitation and sea surface
temperatures in a lot of the southern
hemisphere and a positive correlation
with precip and a lot of the northern
hemisphere but land because SST is not
defined over land it is really there's
no signal and this is unfortunate
because when we're talking about
tropical precipitations and monsoons we
think of the land surface is being very
important and so what we can do it with
this a framework where we're thinking of
theta ii beta is defined over both
equally over both land and ocean and so
what I've done is I've regressed here in
the top plot I've the coastlines are
very faint here but you can see here is
Australia and this is India and
Indochina Peninsula and again in Africa
and I've drawn a box not around the
Sahel but around the heavily
precipitating region in the south asian
monsoon and a john hurley who's at
postdoc in my group i did this work
where he regressed sub cloud theta e on
this precipitation index for south asia
and what you get is is interesting
because it shows that you get elevated
theta e over this continental india
region and it's elevated enough that
basically the land ocean theta e
contrast increases when you do that just
with temperature this is a sort of
surface air temperature
you see that actually during the rainy
years you actually have reduced surface
air temperature over India with some
elevation sort of north of the monsoon
region sub cloud specific humidity
increases over India in the region where
it's cool so what happens is that during
rainy years the boundary layer is cooler
and moister which is no surprise but
what's interesting is that the two don't
just compensate for I mean it's it's
it's um when we think of precipitation
simply cooling a surface we're using
sort of conservation of energy right we
think that some of the energy that's in
the dry heat goes into the water vapor
content but theta II is is a conserved
variable equivalent potential
temperature is a conservative area
belitz roughly a measure of the energy
content of the boundary layer so the
humidity increases enough that it more
than compensates for the cooling of the
boundary layer and this really shows the
power of working in this conserved
variable framework where if you if you
look at temperature or humidity alone
you get these noisier signals that don't
really show you that we don't really
have a theoretical framework to think
about how sub cloud temperature relates
to monsoon strength because we know that
during the Rainier years it's actually
cooler than in the wetter yours but this
shows that we can use a simple idea of
land ocean theta II contrast being
enhanced during stronger monsoon years
that that sort of works on an intro
annual basis and when we look at other
monsoon regions something somewhat
similar seems to hold up but with some
interesting caveats so this is the same
plot that I showed you earlier here the
green boxes are the boxes in which I'm
defining the precipitation index and the
colors represent the regression of theta
II onto the precipitation index within
each region and you can see that here in
sort of West Africa and Australia we
have been enhanced we have enhanced beta
e over the continent during rainy years
and same thing for sort of North America
South America is a little
bit more noisy but what's interesting is
that in contrast with South Asia this
these signals in these other regions are
really confined on the sort of on the
poleward edge and even even further
poleward of the region of the end of the
main precipitation which is inside this
box and that's that's quite interesting
because sort of moving on to the fourth
part of my talk now it invokes the
potential importance of deserts so this
plot that I showed you earlier for the
Sahel we drew a box around the
precipitating region which is outlined
in blue contours here and the colors on
this plot are an estimate of how
vegetated the surface is from satellite
radiation measurements and you can see
that the plot that I showed you of the
theta II regressed onto the cell
precipitation index showed during rainy
years in the Sahel you actually say de
elevated over this region just poleward
of the precipitating region when we saw
the plot for Australia we saw that theta
II boundary layer theta you is elevated
over this broad region of the
continental interior of Australia whole
word of this precipitating region and so
that's interesting because we don't
really usually think of the thermal the
thermodynamic properties of deserts
being related strongly to monsoon
rainfall and but but perhaps we should
that this is a plot that shows what the
circulation looks like in a vertical
plane over three different monsoon
regions and let's start off here on the
bottom left which is northern Africa and
so here the the summer pole is on the
right and so latitude and the bottom
pressure or height on on the vertical
axis
and what I'm plotting is the Myrtle
circulation so red vectors denote upward
strong upward motion blue vectors denote
strong downward motion and this a deep
tropospheric overturning circulation is
is our canonical monsoon overturning
sell the black line represents where the
boundary layer theta e maximum is and
its load and it sort of is serves quite
nicely as the poleward limit of this
strong thermally direct monsoon
circulation but the interesting thing
here is that if you look at the strong
upward motion you see that I it has a
sort of shallow branch located poleward
of the deep branch we see this here in
Africa and then when we look at the
southern hemisphere look at Australia
and Southern Africa where this summer
pole is now on the Left we see this deep
monsoon overturning but then we see
certs we see shallow ascent poleward of
the deepest scent and this is really
just your desert heat low so this is
warm air rising over the desert that
lies poleward of the monsoon region and
flowing toward the equator flowing into
this deep moist barrow clinic
overturning circulation and I'm just
going to close with that to keep this
somewhat short but sort of summarize in
this schematic here what I've talked to
you about today and I'm going to leave
you with this open question about desert
circulations a Ravi Shekhar was a grad
student in my group now is actually
working on this topic for his thesis of
the importance of those circulations but
in summary monsoon circulations are
ultimately caused by radial gradients in
in solar insulation right but but over
ocean that's absorbed and there's a
great lag because of the great heat
capacity of the ocean over land the
installation is communicated quite
quickly to the atmosphere by surface
heat fluxes
and thinking about the influence of that
that radial gradient in in energy source
through the boundary layer theta II and
the free tropospheric temperature
provides this nice framework that we can
use to think about monsoon circulations
and I showed you that when you put a
mountain between the moist the warm and
moist monsoon area and the desert that
lies poleward of monsoon regions you
create this orographic barrier that can
prevent this low theta air from the
desert from penetrating into this
monsoon region and that allows this this
batter later theta e to increase beyond
what it would otherwise be and this this
thermally direct circulation to become
more intense and even shift poleward in
contrast when you take that mountain
away in the monsoon regions over
Australia Africa both north and south of
the Equator you actually have
communication between this desert and
the monsoon region you have this shallow
overturning circulation that can adapt
dry air from this desert region into the
convecting region and shift with beta e
maximum and the monsoon thermal maximum
toward the equator and decrease their
intensity and we've seen some evidence
from observations that there's
interannual variability in monsoon
rainfall in the strength of the
circulation in the boundary layer theta
D and what I didn't show you is that
these um these shallow circulations
actually vary in intensity to that
during during rainy monsoon years these
shallow circulations seem to decrease in
intensity and whether that's causative
or whether it simply is a co variation
between monsoon strength and the desert
heat low is a very much an open question
and that's something we're working on
now so I'll just leave it with that into
questions